[Music]
eight new coaches in the
2019 nfl season and there are the
projected win totals from the folks in
vegas high hopes for the browns and for
the packers both at nine
i can't i can't get used to seeing the
browns have those expectations but we
better get used to it broncos and jets
at seven each buccaneers and
bengals at six each and the dolphins and
the cardinals at five wins each at least
one new head coach has made the playoffs
in his first year for 13 straight
seasons that happens when there's six
seven or eight new coaches every year
the law of averages means one of these
guys is going to turn around matt and
aggie did it last year with the bears
became the coach of the year and you
know this year
freddie kitchens the browns coach
recently said you know they've gotten
better on paper but you know we hear
that all the time well but you still
have to go out and do it there's a lot
of pressure on him this year i'd say a
lot of pressure on matt lafleur as well
in green bay yeah when you look at those
wind totals projected on the right side
of 500 if they fail hey it's not because
of the talent it's because of the coach
chris no i know there's going to be a
lot of pressure on both those guys
certainly matt lafleur we knew that was
going to be the the case for him anyways
when you have aaron rodgers as your
quarterback and the green bay packers
who they are a storied franchise yeah
there's there's a bullseye on you per se
but you know i do look at the browns
with the the win total of nine the
packers of the win total of nine and go
oh you know hey i certainly can see both
of those teams winning 10 football games
the packers you know again with mike
pettin on defense matt lefleur uh you
know nathaniel hackett is offensive
coordinator there on the offensive side
of the ball i think the offense will be
schematically more creative and better
than it has been in years past and i
think the packers made some right moves
on the defensive side of the ball to
improve that as well and i think that
was already trending in the right
direction with some of the young talent
they got last year and the year before
in the draft and mike pettin's been
really good other team that jumps out to
me mike just if i had a pick like out of
the list we just showed there of the
teams you know the bucks would be one
team i would look out to just go watch
out there's some things there that i
like there's talent on the d-line the
o-line's pretty damn good peyton
barbour's a pretty good running back i
think jameis winston will really benefit
from bruce arians they still got mike
evans and o.j howard and chris godwin a
wide receiver so they have some things
as far as you know common formulas that
you look at for a team to make a run
they have some of them and i would say
i'd keep my eye on the bucks and bruce
arians
especially since there are real
questions about the other teams in the
nfc south right now can the saints dig
out of zero and zero for the second
straight year after having a
heartbreaking end of the season yeah and
is drew brees starting to lose the race
with father time that he inevitably will
lose where are the falcons now where are
the panthers with with cam newton in his
shoulder injury and his commitment to
play at 235 which may be a mistake so i
think there's something to that i think
the buccaneers they're either going to
go way over six or it's going to be a
disaster i i think
six seven eight wins those are the least
likely i think it's going to be a great
season or a horrendous season because
it's either going to work or it's not
going to work for the buccaneers i look
at the cardinals at five and it's
amazing to me how can we peg a win total
for wagering purposes if we don't know
what they're going to do with the first
overall pick yeah right because it
changes everything if they get kyler
murray what if they go nick bosa instead
and stick with josh rosen so you know
if you have an idea what the team's
going to do in the draft that's going to
shape
what their chances are in the in the
regular season it does seem a little
premature to be thinking about this
though because what happens in the draft
is going to change our view of what
these teams are going to do during the
regular season yeah it definitely does
you're right we don't have the complete
picture of the football team right now
you know with the arizona cardinals like
you said though five wins i don't know i
mean hey if they got kyler murray or
josh rosen in a quarterback i don't
think it really matters i think they're
kind of dancing around maybe that four
to six win maybe seven wins you know
okay maybe kylo murray's worth an extra
win and some big moments late in the
game to pull them through whatever it
may be
regardless there's just a lot of holes
on that cardinals roster with an
unproven head coach so i think that's
why you see the win total there as far
as five wins it's just uh
you know again i don't know if kyle
murray is gonna make that bump up a
whole lot more maybe another another win
mike maybe maybe it goes to six if they
drafted him in number one
yeah maybe six maybe seven i don't know
i mean if he takes the league by storm
like baker mayfield did last year then
maybe he's worth two or three or four
more maybe in five depending but you
gotta factor in the competition as well
if the 49ers stay healthy the rams are
the rams right the seahawks the seahawks
yeah they're gonna have a harder they
could be a better team yeah they could
do they could be a much better team in
arizona and still win only four games
for the full year how about the jets at
seven adam gase the new head coach three
of the last four jets head coaches have
made the playoffs in their first year on
the job
is
is it too much to think that gase can
you know he knows that division well
he's going to be very motivated to play
the dolphins we joke with him about that
when he's on the show and and he says
enough to make it clear those two games
he's going to be highly motivated he
knows the bills he knows the patriots
could the jets climb the ma
the mountain and get to the postseason
after you know after the bucks for the
team that i would say watch out for the
jets would be my next pick there i mean
the way sam darnold ended the year
certainly uh you know again i think
there's things on the roster guys like
quincy and nuno and robbie anderson that
are kind of under the radar really good
football players from maybe the
mainstream media media but then you add
le'veon bell and jameson crowder a
really awesome slot receiver to the mix
there i go whoa that offense and adam
gase now you know running the show there
that's interesting and greg williams on
the defensive side of the ball um you
know certainly the jets defense it does
have some talent they're missing one
thing on that jets defense where you
just go if they had this you'd go watch
out they don't have an elite pass rusher
other than that they got everything else
they got defensive tackles they got good
middle linebacker play now uh was
certainly with cj mosley uh the
secondary's good they got young talent
jermaine johnson's there jamal adams i'd
say is the best safety in football the
jets would certainly be a team i'd say
watch out for to be in that wild card
discussion this year
jets at seven wins and the broncos at
seven wins in that division that has the
chiefs and the chargers and if the
raiders are better and joe flacco's the
quarterback
look i i don't get this one i i i'm not
i'm not saying it's going to be a
horrible year for the broncos but
they're going to be hard-pressed to get
north of seven wins chris i i see i hear
you mike when i first saw seven wins i
went oh okay and then i kind of thought
about it and then the same thing you're
you're talking about i mean the chargers
and chiefs they're set up you know i
just can't imagine them falling off the
cliff very much as far as where they
were last year the oakland raiders are
going to be a desperate football team
this year john gruden's going to want to
you know put his best foot forward to
kind of get things going in the right
direction for that organization so they
are they're in a tough spot with a lot
of different questions there but
offensive line play is gonna be improved
i do like joe flacco and that defense
still has got some talented football
players on it to where hey i understand
it i you know seven wins i think it's
fair i would say it was probably
six or seven is probably where i would
have pegged them at
and you know one we haven't talked about
specifically the dolphins at five
i don't think they want to win five and
i know that brian flores the head coach
isn't going to come out and say it but
stephen ross the owner of the team had
he made some comments last week publicly
and maybe not publicly indicating that
they they get it they understand that
that this is going to be a rough year
and sometimes you have to do that to get
to where you want to be it's been 20
years since they had a franchise
quarterback in dan marino and if they
want to set themselves up to earn that
right to get a franchise quarterback you
need to have the bottom fall out for one
year and that's the great disconnect
that the nfl will not acknowledge that
there is a true incentive to be as bad
as you can be if you know you're going
to be bad be as bad as you can be
because then you get the highest
possible draft pick and then you can get
better faster especially if you can get
yourself a franchise quarterback and we
saw it with baker mayfield and the
browns we may see it with kyle murray
this year and maybe the dolphins will be
the team we're talking about a year from
now chris who
has earned that top spot in the draft
and is hoping that they can get their
dan marino yeah well they're not tanking
but they're rebuilding they can say
whatever they want
i mean i do believe rebuilding implies
that they've never been any what are
they rebuilt they're not they're just
building well yeah i know they went to
the playoffs a couple of years ago but
it seems like it was 20 years ago no i
know it seems like it was 20 years ago
but it was two years ago they went to
the playoffs or you know so i i i or it
was three years ago i believe i think
we're wrong i think we're a year off
there but regardless of 2016. yeah it
was 2016. so but regardless yeah i mean
i hear you but it's a total re-haul of
the organization let's say that and i
think everything you need to know about
them and what they're doing you know
first of all hiring you know getting
ryan fitzpatrick a quarterback right get
a steady veteran presence in there he's
the starter we'll see what we do with
the draft or whatever else but the
biggest thing i look at is ryan
tannehill uh and robert quinn being
traded with them paying part of the
money to acquire the assets assets is
the key word for me for the miami
dolphins because they're looking for
those assets to make future moves so
they're getting guys out the door paying
a little money if they got to but
regardless they're going to get some
draft picks back because they want to
make some moves and probably be
aggressive here maybe this year but
certainly next year in the off season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports